you might think of soap as anything that
washes but in chemistry soap actually
has a very specific meaning it refers to
cleanses made from fats and oils reacted
with a strong base usually lye or sodium
hydroxide soaps are the oldest cleanses
and they're natural but they're actually
quite irritating on your skin first off
soaps don't work when they're acidic so
these true soaps have a high pH your
skin is acidic with a low PH so the high
pH of soaps can disturb your skin
secondly they have very skinny straight
structures so they can get into your
skin more easily and stay there which
means you get prolonged irritation if
you see these high up in the ingredient
lists it's probably going to be a more
irritating cleanser so that's why soap
free cleansers were invented they use
gentler surfactants these days a lot of
things that look like bar soaps might
not actually be bar soaps for example
Dove Beauty Bar and Cetaphil gentle
cleansing bar use isothyanates
surfactants so they can drastically cut
down on the amount of real soap and be
formulated at a low PH that make them
much less irritating